Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic
les échelles de l'univers.
L'univers dans lequel nous vivons présente une extrême diversité
Ne serait-ce qu'à notre échelle, il fourmille d'une multitude d'objets,
tous différents les uns les autres.
Cette diversité s'articule en plusieurs niveaux
de complexité qui s'imbriquent les uns dans les autres.
L'univers dans son ensemble est potentiellement de dimension infinie.
Cela dit, depuis sa naissance au moment du Big-bang,
la lumière des astres qui sont trop lointains
n'a pas encore eu le temps de se propager jusqu'à nous.
Tout ce que l'on peut voir dans l'univers
est donc confiné dans une immense sphère,
de près d'un quadrillion de kilomètres,
qu'on appelle "notre univers observable".
A cette échelle, l'univers ressemble à une grande soupe,
un peu comme un fluide composé de filaments de matière noire
sur lesquels viennent se greffer des regroupements de super-amas.
Si l'on plonge dans un super-amas, il est lui-même
constitué d'une multitude d'amas plus petits,
qui sont eux-mêmes formés d'une foule de galaxies.
Si l'on s'intéresse à une galaxie en particulier
par exemple la nôtre, la Voie Lactée,
celle-ci est composée de plusieurs centaines de milliards d'étoiles.
Pour la majeure partie, chacune de ces étoiles
est entourée de multiples planètes, d'astéroïdes,
ou encore de comètes qui lui gravitent autour.
Notre Soleil, l'une de ces étoiles, est situé
en périphérie de la Voie Lactée, dans une zone qu'on appelle
le Bras d'Orion.
Comme pour les autres étoiles, orbite autour de lui
une multitude d'objets, et notamment notre propre planète,
la Terre, qui orbite à plus d'une centaine
de millions de kilomètres de l'étoile.
Lorsqu'on se rapproche de la Terre
celle-ci possède un satellite naturel : la Lune.
Ainsi qu'une myriade de satellites artificiels
envoyés par les humains depuis le milieu du XXème siècle.
A sa surface, la Terre présente d'importants reliefs
comme le mont Everest qui s'élève à près de 9 km
au-dessus du niveau de la mer.
S'enchainent ensuite les plus grandes constructions humaines
tours et gratte-ciel qui peuvent atteindre des centaines de mètres.
Enfin, les plantes, les êtres humains
ainsi que la plupart des mammifères
mesurent environ quelques mètres.
C'est notre échelle et celle des objets que l'on côtoie au quotidien.
On l'appelle parfois "l'échelle macroscopique".
En s'intéressant à des objets de plus en plus petits,
on pénètre alors dans le monde microscopique.
C'est l'échelle des cellules et des organismes vivants
les plus petits.
On trouve principalement des bactéries
qui mesurent quelques millièmes de millimètres
et des virus dont la taille peut atteindre quelques dizaines micromètres.
Encore plus profondément dans la matière,
tous les objets sont composés de molécules
qui sont elles-mêmes formées d'atomes.
Un atome consiste en un nuage d'électrons
au centre duquel se trouve un noyau
dont la taille est dix mille fois plus petite que l'atome dans son ensemble.
Le noyau atomique
est lui-même constitué de composants plus petits :
les protons et les neutrons
qui sont eux-mêmes formés de quarks.
On entre alors dans le monde subatomique.
C'est l'échelle des particules élémentaires
c'est-à-dire les constituants fondamentaux à la base de la matière.
Enfin, si l'on plonge encore plus profondément,
il est possible d'atteindre un palier de taille infime
de l'ordre du centième de millionièmes de milliardièmes
de milliardième de nanomètres
à partir duquel les principes même de distances et de longueurs
perdent leur sens.
C'est ce qu'on appelle "l'échelle de Plank"
De l'univers observable à l'échelle de Plank,
notre monde peut être étudié sous toutes ses coutures.
De l'infiniment grand à l'infiniment petit,
la façon selon laquelle les scientifiques vont décrire l'univers
va changer en fonction de l'échelle qui les intéresse.
A l'échelle du cosmos et des grandes structures,
on utilisera plutôt la relativité générale d'Einstein,
qui voit l'univers comme un tout : l'espace-temps,
déformé par les objets qu'il contient.
A notre échelle, on utilisera plutôt la mécanique classique
beaucoup plus simple, qui se base sur les principes
du mouvement de Newton.
et qui possède une large gamme d'applications concrètes.
Enfin, à l'échelle des atomes et des particules les plus fondamentales
on utilisera plutôt la mécanique quantique
qui permet de décrire les phénomènes étranges qui apparaissent à cette échelle.
Cela dit
bien que nos modèles théoriques soient de plus en plus perfectionnés,
les scientifiques sont encore à la recherche d'une théorie unique
qui permettrait d'unifier toutes les échelles de l'univers,
de le décrire dans son ensemble ainsi qu'à l'échelle la plus fondamentale
et en particulier d'unifier la gravitation avec la physique quantique.
Pour conclure, l'univers présente une grande diversité
en termes de distance et de longueur
Mais il présente également d'autres types d'échelles
et on peut par exemple s'intéresser aux différentes échelles de temps.
L'âge de l'univers est estimé à 13,8 milliards d'années.
Sur Terre, il aura fallu près d'une cinquantaine de millions d'années
pour passer d'un petit mammifère terrestre
à nos baleines actuelles.
Une vie humaine quant à elle
est de l'ordre de la centaine d'années.
Pour un être humain, il faut environ un dixième de secondes
pour cligner des yeux.
Le quark bottom
qui est une particule élémentaire instable
se désintègre en moyenne
après un millième de milliardièmes de secondes.
Le quark top quant à lui
qui est beaucoup plus instable
se désintègre après un temps ridiculement bref
de quelques centièmes de quadrillionièmes de secondes.
Enfin, comme dans le cas des longueurs
il existe un temps infime
de quelques centièmes de septillionièmes de secondes
en-dessous duquel la notion même de durée
perd tout son sens.
C'est ce qu'on appelle "le temps de Plank".